good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast and happy monday excuse me
oh my god hope everyone had an amazing
weekend hit jax how you doing um darn
good we had an amazing weekend beyond
speaking of amazing weekends it was such
like a long
jam-packed fun weekend i'm so tired
today but i'm just riding high on the
memories yeah i'm like i'm in a low if
i'm if i'm not if i'm gonna be honest
well what goes up must come down and you
were on such a high so on thursday night
after talking about it for 75 years i
performed my final show in new york city
at madison square garden theater
and msgt theater
and msg
and it was
incredible i was
first of all i remember
i was in my bathroom like before i left
for the venue like just like sitting on
the toilet thinking like the next time i
sit on this toilet like this huge
milestone will be behind me and i'll be
so relieved like i'm so jealous of the
girl who's gonna be taking a poop
tomorrow because she will have
accomplished you know this huge feat
right and that was kind of my sentiment
the whole time like just get it behind
me and then we can celebrate um and you
can attest to the fact that i was like
literally like a wretched wench before
the show like i was so [ __ ] nervous
like the magnitude of it all really
started to hit me and i was like being
actually a monster like yelling at
everyone like not okay i've seen you be
more monstrous
on your like monstrous scale it wasn't
off the charts and like you had every
reason to be nervous and like it was
just people who were bringing bad energy
had to go everyone was like everyone's
energy was like toxic to me not everyone
even like two people yeah but even if
they were being fine i was like you are
being so toxic like you have to leave
but it wasn't me it wasn't you it wasn't
yeah it wasn't it wasn't any of the
girls no no no it was just voice
but everyone was having fun and i was um
i was just so excited for it to be done
and the second it was done like i fell
into a deep dark depression like i am
like it's that's it that's the thing
about life i know you get so excited for
these things
and they're fleeting and then it's all
behind you and i also think for us we're
always just like waiting for big things
to be behind us like we you don't enjoy
the moment you're just like i want this
to be in the rear view and then you're
like well [ __ ] it's over no like looking
forward so much to like this i'm looking
forward so much to like taking my bow
like i missed the whole thing right
you're not looking forward to the event
you're looking forward to the feeling of
when it's over no exactly and like the
emphasis i put on being done i'm like
mad at myself even though like when i
was on stage like i really tried to be
super present and enjoy every minute of
it like have fun it felt like from the
audience that you were having a blast
like
i don't know how the other shows have
gone but it felt like it was never
ending like it was such a journey
and it was like so long and beautiful
and it felt like you were just like
enjoying yourself i really really was
like once i got out there and like it
wasn't as bad as i thought it was gonna
be i was like oh okay like let's do this
and i had like literally the most fun of
my life and i think i probably delivered
my best performance to date like ever
um i also did 90 minutes which i usually
go for like 60 to 70 but i was like just
taking my time having fun like i really
didn't want to leave yeah so you're
making a meal out of it i was making a
meal like i was literally setting up
shop i was moving in anyways like we all
came to the garden like we're in no rush
to go right and i have drinks we have
spritz like
give us a show and i think that i did
and i'm like so
proud of myself i'm also so sad like i
really can't put into words like how i
don't think i'll ever be able to capture
the electricity of that night like your
first show
new york city madison square garden my
hair makeup looked amazing like i looked
snatched i it was just
it was the perfect storm of perfection
it was the perfect storm of perfection
and going into the night i knew it was
going to be a big night for so many
reasons like obviously end log at msgt
and that is major it's my first night
out as a new mom and it's your biggest
crowd yet but i and i knew that i would
be overwhelmed because like everything
makes me emotional these days and true
to form it did but like walking out the
toasters were
bigger and better than ever i felt so
proud of you like i can't even explain i
know that like we've built this
community together and to see the
toasters out was like iconic but like
you go out there every night like you
put yourself out there you started the
second tour after cove people didn't
know if they were going to live shows
like the covid wave was so up and down
for us and like to see it all come
together and the last time i was out
really was the beacon show and like this
wasn't was even bigger triple the size
dare i say like the crowd even there was
more fervor and zest
and i feel like everyone there like knew
how big of a deal the night was like for
you and even for me just like having
birth stomach yeah and now going like it
was just it was overwhelming i was so
moved thank you by the whole thing i was
so proud of you you were so [ __ ]
funny
when teacher smiles teacher is happy
when teacher frowns teacher is sad
i literally am so excited for jackie to
start using quotes jackie loves to quote
my previous show just grace queen and
now that you have new material that
makes me so happy and just to piggyback
off of what you said like i think no
matter what like
playing a show in front of 6000 people
when you started doing comedy four years
ago like i was so proud of myself but i
think why it felt so much better is
because like we've been knocked down so
many [ __ ] times we have rebuilt this
business more than once like and so just
to like accomplish things but really a
lot of times feels like so many of the
odds are stacked against you like it
feels even more
good more accomplishing because it
wasn't easy like nothing in life is easy
but i feel like sometimes things are
harder for us like i really and i'm sure
everyone feels that way but like that is
how i feel sometimes so to see like and
also we sit in here there's four of us
in this room right that's the thing it's
like the personification of your work in
real life is jarring yeah because we sit
here and we really talk to each other
tons of people are watching but we don't
feel that every day so to see it in real
life it was so overwhelming and like
there's no better energy than toaster
energy 100 at msg and the venue was so
huge there were so many people i took a
video and like the crowd never ends no
no it was so big and you know what
usually like when i do sound check we
test the lighting and i don't like it to
be so dark because you know i want to
see the people but when we did
soundcheck i was like i don't want to
see one foot in front of me because if i
see how many
rows of people are stacked up like i
will cry
so it was pitch for me i lit i know
shannon ford and tasha were sitting in
the front row because shannon was like i
want to come to your show i'm like great
how many tickets do you need she's like
are you kidding and then she sent me a
screenshot she brought front row seats
my [ __ ] what are you doing let me give
you my i get free seats like let me get
she's like no i want to support so she
was in the front row in the middle and i
didn't even see her like because i made
it so bright for me that like you can't
see anyone and i'm so glad that i did
because when i
bowed and
finished the show they turned the lights
on for me to see everyone and i was like
oh my like that's how many people were
like thank god i didn't know i would
have done such a bad job if i could
really grasp the magnitude of how many
people were in that room yeah six
thousand that's insane i feel that
completely yes so many people so many
people and there was also a rangers game
going on that night and like the rangers
fans walking through the lobby like
seeing the toasters they were like what
is going on i'm like what are you doing
here like this is disgusting and
disrespectful actually really kind of
rude of the rangers to have a game um
the night that i was performing no but
there was like extra cheers you could
hear them cheering i hope they i'm
assuming they won yeah they did they did
so it was a big night it sounded hardy
it was a big mess and then also when we
were leaving the venue like in um our
car and we were leaving through like you
know the artist entrance you could see
all the ranger's fans like really
thinking there were rangers in our car
and we didn't want to take the window
down and just ruin it when i pulled up
um there were like so many fans on
behind barricades like waiting just
wanting to take pictures of each player
showing up my window was open and
they're like who the [ __ ] is this fat
[ __ ] like
is she someone's mom
is she a player's at
i was like hi
and they were all wearing rangers gears
and they're like can you move there's
another car behind you like we need you
to get back and the same thing happened
when we left like fans waiting waiting
waiting and i was like let's open the
window you were like no don't crush
their children no because they get to go
home and say like we saw a car like
maybe it was wayne gretzky like who hear
me or yogurt and let's let them have
that dream forever there were young kids
they'll remember that night yeah
on their dad's shoulders as opposed to
us rolling down the window and then
saying who the [ __ ] is this
you're right no we did the right thing
we did the right thing
we are just making dreams we're just
thinking dream comes true it's literally
like what what we do for others it's
literally the grand prospect hall we
make your dreams come true yeah and then
we headed to the after party which was
just diabolically unwell yes i was
unwell i was just like so happy to be
done oh my god also the juice checks
were there
literally everyone i've ever met in my
life was there yeah yeah and it was just
like it was incredible like finally like
it was behind me i could really like
relax it was so fun obviously i didn't
want it to end so like i of course was
like the last one at the party and then
i went out to the club afterwards i fell
i literally got to the club and i bought
a table like thinking like i just sold
out msg like let me buy this table for
everyone i bought the table they handed
me my credit card back the second the
woman handed it to me i fell and i left
it wouldn't have been a successful night
if you didn't fall though like that's
not any a fall that you should feel
shame over i have absolutely no no
regrets no regrets i don't even think i
don't even want to unburden myself the
fall my friend abe thank god for it like
he did catch me a little bit but not
nothing was stopping let it rip nothing
stopping me from truly hitting the deck
like yeah boom and so i left the second
we got to the club i paid for the table
everyone got to enjoy and i didn't even
enjoy but she never stops giving you
guys no regards no regrets it was
the best night of my life and like i
didn't think we could top beacon night
and this was just i just felt so much
more confident in myself like as a
comedian i was so i'm so proud of the
material that i wrote like there's so
many like straight up just zingers in
there you know like that
obviously everything's funny and you
make you're so physical and you make
everything even funnier like teacher is
sad like isn't necessarily like funny
but the way that you you had me rolling
and i did feel like the campers were
representing 100 um and maybe the
cameras like influence that moment 100
um
but you literally there were so many
jokes that were just like wow that's a
plus comedy oh and like to top it all
off like may 5th is our dad's birthday
so there was like a special energy in
the air for all of us it was like
emotional special yeah you know
there was so it was obviously such a
professional achievement but there were
so many personal elements too
and it all culminated in just being a
really special overwhelming positively
overwhelming evening i agree and i woke
up just like so sad and like that's
where i'm at now but i did get like a
boost of serotonin because the next
night like for us nothing happens for
weeks go by weeks go by
we don't we don't leave our house then
like two huge moments all happened in
one weekend which was just exhausting
but you know what it was meant to happen
that way snitch's birthday was the next
day she threw herself a fabulous 25th
birthday like really premium and full of
influencers which i was loving like the
tick tockers like i was literally
lurking in the corner like you're trying
to get in their tick-tock she was and i
was like claudia get in there like this
is your chance and they opened they
welcomed you with open arms you said
they were so happy to have you they were
so lovely willing to share their
platforms with me their tips and tricks
and it was amazing yeah it was a quite
an influential event like finally
getting to see all these influencers
that snitching's out with and they're
such lovely no so like there's such love
lovely girls i just want to go through
some of my my favorite moments first of
all just like getting to spend
a moment with shannon ford is really a
blessing upon our household she is
so cool and like just
being in her presence made me feel cool
and i was like so grateful that she
showed up for counselor yeah and i just
i [ __ ] love shannon i i'm so happy
that you do i love her as well i haven't
gotten like i saw her a year ago before
like right when before i was pregnant
like we had lunch and i hadn't really
seen her since and so it was great to
spend the weekend with her and she's
just everything she's everything and
sophia la corte was there and i just the
way i would take a bullet for that girl
yeah obsessed it's crazy like the
redheads are really like coming through
no there was a photo of you sophia and
shannon like three premium natural
redheads it was it was almost too much
to bear i know and like for me
just being next to them
it's a lot no but they probably feel the
same about you honestly not not these
days no they do i swear thanks
um serena kerrigan who like i just
am in love with like i'm just obsessed
these girls they're so nice and like so
nice they're so pretty and they're so
funny and like they're just all like
when you watch all these people on tick
tock you just don't know what they're
going to be like in person but they're
all just like lovely normal girls and
they're all like showed up for margot it
was such a fun party i was literally
like i got there i was like okay i'm
going to stay for as long as like
i can get away with
i'm not gonna drink just gonna like
chill just gonna support your sister
support my sister and then i got there
and they're like there was all these
like sprit society um ice luges and free
tequila it was like a sickening party i
was like i have to partake right and
then i just got away from me and i ended
up home at four o'clock and the theme
was glitz and glam so like everyone
really showed up and showed out so it's
just like you know sometimes people look
like slobs
but cinch like
demanded that everyone come best like in
their best wear
and so it really was an elevated event
for that reason agreed like she left no
box on unchecked like the music was
sickening the venue was sickening
everyone's outfits looked great and it
was just good to be with everyone even
though we were literally with them the
night before but i did not get a chance
to like speak to anyone the night before
and i was so blacked out um that i had
like more normal conversations with
people the second night for me the first
night i was like catching up with
everyone like how's harry showing
pictures like literally being in like
such a mom mode like going through my
pictures by the second night i had all
my favorite i favorited all the photos
that i wanted to see so i could just
slide through not like looking through
my phone like a grandma right um but the
first night i was like catching up with
everyone and the second night i could
like just talk about other stuff enjoy
yeah and so like
now having been an on the town nyc
nightlife two nights in a row like how
are you feeling it was exhausting like
the next day i could barely move and i
didn't even really drink
period like i think at snitch's birthday
i had one spritz total over the course
of opening and leaving many spritzes
around and not knowing which one was
mine um and for your party i didn't end
up drinking at all really because i just
like never got i i i
didn't i didn't consider it
um
and i i pumped at the garden for you it
was so iconic you guys jackie just
pumping at the garden and then just like
putting all my milk in my purse it was
so iconic going to the after party how
was the lv the louis vuitton so the lv
pump is it's really a cool concept and i
think that's like you know why people
gravitate towards it it definitely
didn't get all the milk out that i had
and i was like not sure if milk was
coming out it was like a little finicky
but it's a cool concept that i look
forward to exploring further but and i
did get some out but also if you leave a
lot in there like that so you could get
a clogged up so i could see how it could
go haywire but then for the next night i
was just like you know i pumped right
before i left and i pumped right when i
got home and i didn't need to bring all
that stuff with me but i knew for years
like it was a much longer yeah it was a
long day yeah so it was exhausting to be
out on the town
wearing heels was crippling i wore them
to your show and it really ruined my
night yeah i just had to keep finding a
seat everywhere i went so then the next
night i wore boots because i was like
i'm not doing this again but i need to
invest in some better heels oh also for
margo's birthday
we had
at brunch at bergdorf's and it was such
a fun day and we went did a little
shopping and i'm really just trying to
invest in my shoe game because even
though i like have cool shoes they're a
little like too cool and funky so i
never actually wear them and i wind up
wearing my white loafers every single
day so i'm investing in like more flats
and i think you guys are gonna start to
see that come through even though today
my shoes are from shoedazzle cute
also the one thing getting me through
the weekend like my feet were broken my
back was broken my neck was broken my
[ __ ] my crack the whole thing
um we had the bright idea like two weeks
ago for mother's day to book massages
and i was like we are [ __ ] geniuses
no one on the planet has ever been more
smarter than us because the only thing
getting me through i woke up on friday
morning i could not walk my feet were
like swollen
i was wearing heels the whole night
getting a massage yesterday was the
perfect way to spend sunday of mother's
day and sunday after all we've been
through this weekend right exactly my
massage literally felt like 20 minutes
at the end like i knew that it was
ending
and i was so so sad usually like it
sneaks up on me and i'm like oh okay but
i was like i think this is it i think
she's about to say her goodbyes like
please come back
it went by so quickly which is a sign of
a good massage 100 but it was really um
it was fleeting i just
we won't have a weekend like that for a
while i actually have a crazy weekend
this week i'm going to austin in l.a i'm
actually going to a little concert on
sunday so oh yeah all the girlies bought
tickets to a concert and nobody decided
to invite me well we're kind of like the
crew who goes to this particular artist
it's so sweet it's like have a group
chat the way i was like so left out
you're not you didn't even know i was
going to be in l.a you didn't know no i
didn't but dana put it together so take
it up with her will do yeah will do will
do
so i really just thank everyone who came
it was amazing i'm so glad we could have
all been there for that historic night
together historic and i just can't wait
to do it again like gotta get back to
the drawing board yeah
yeah yeah good luck to you thank you i
mean we would all go see it i would see
it again 100. um
so i think is that everything i don't
know you could jump in yeah
it's like weird also the stories blow
the stories yeah no like when i was
looking for stories this morning there
were a lot of mediocre stories so i had
to just choose five mediocre ones so
there's like mediocre ones i didn't
choose you know yeah but the thing is
like we are so not mediocre that it'll
right i'm not concerned and we've got
unburdened yourselves which is our
favorite segment for mondays so we've
got a great show let's jump right in to
the past five stories the fast mediocre
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
today's episode is brought to you by
credit karma personal loans are you
planning ahead for a big expense don't
put those car repairs or medical bills
on a high interest credit card credit
karma can help you look for a
low-interest personal loan that could
save you money while you pay off your
purchases credit karma uses your credit
data to find loan offers that are
personalized to you so you can have a
better idea of what loan amount you can
get approved for credit karma will even
show you your chances of approval so you
can choose between loan offers that
you're more likely to get approved for
and apply with more confidence
comparing loans
on credit karma is 100 free it won't
affect your credit score and it could
save you money credit karma apply with
more confidence today so if you're ready
to apply head to creditkarma.com
loan offers to see personalized offers
that's creditkarma.com
loanoffers to find the loan for you
creditkarma.com
loan offers
today's episode is also brought to you
by bruce the electric toothbrush that
will change the way you think about
brushing your teeth with powerful sonic
technology and ultra gentle bristles the
brush redefines what it means to have
super clean teeth it's like that feeling
when you just leave the dentist a fresh
whole clean mouth but it's every single
day so when you get the brush kit it
includes the electric toothbrush three
extra brush heads a magnetic charging
station
and a sleek travel case the battery life
on a brush lasts an entire 30 days on
one full charge so it makes it the
perfect brush
to travel with and keep your countertop
charge cord free it's slim and sleek and
it makes it easy to throw in your purse
or your bag on the daily it has six
unique modes for every type of brusher
from gentle for sensitive gums to white
to improve tough surface stains and
everything in between don't forget also
about the tongue mode for that stinky
breath if you're a breathy queen use the
brush
the tongue brush mode
they also
have a two-minute timer because most
people only brush for 45 seconds even
though dentists recommend a full two
minutes so their quad pacer helps you
make the most out of these two minutes
by pausing every 30 seconds to ensure
that you clean every part of your mouth
get 20 off when you pick up your bruce
brush kit and plan when you go to
bruce.com toast that's 20 off when you
go to bruce.com toast
b-r-u-u-s-h dot com slash toast you know
maybe that's why the energy and the
smiles of everyone in the audience at
msg were so bright because you know all
of them were using bruce i didn't smell
one ounce of smelly breath when i walked
on stage except my own and you know they
went to bruce shotgun
love to see it you do okay first up a
little book news britney spears confirms
her tell-all book will come out at the
end of the year she said i want to talk
about secrets a few months after a judge
ruled that britney's conservatorship
must come to an end a report revealed
that britney signed a 15 million book
deal with simon schuster for a tell-all
memoir i did not know that detail while
britney has yet to speak about the
specific terms of the deal she has
confirmed that she is indeed in the
process of writing that book in various
posts that pop singer has opened up
about her process with the book
including how she feels about certain
memories when she reflects on them in a
more recent post she revealed that the
book will arrive at the end of the year
and she says i want to talk about
secrets
um is she pregnant
i feel like remember that was like that
whole hoopla and i wasn't really sure we
haven't really heard about it no i know
i feel like it's just going to kind of
like go away because i really don't
i don't know i
i'm waiting for more uh information
information but i am very curious about
this book like this seems very
legit by the end of the year is quick
yeah and i
i believe she's working with a writer so
a lot of celebs some of my favorite
summary memoirs are written with writers
and they're they do a really good job of
like because for a celebrity like they
can just sit and talk and they know what
happened but like for someone to put it
in it's so much easier and i think it's
a better process so i'm sure britney has
she could write an anthology an
encyclopedia um
so i do think it'll be really good when
it comes out yeah i think so too i also
just wanted to talk about books in
general because i just finished gary
jannetty's book oh don't start with that
you said it was amazing it was really
good and there's so many parts that i
know you're going to die over both of
his books now are both so good and if
you like to read even a little bit
definitely check them out it was like
they're so short so if you're a short
queen like me they're so short it's my
first five star book of the year but i
do rate celebrity like memoir
non-fiction books on a different scale
than fiction books yeah but still it was
five stars it was really [ __ ] good no
it's on my list like i so want to go on
vacation because like i really want to
enjoy it like on a beach
i think sometimes the place in which you
read a book can affect your rating
definitely like if you're on a gorgeous
hammock looking over a seaside cliff
like whatever piece of trash you're
reading like it's going to be amazing
yeah also the time it takes you to read
the book
affects it too because sometimes if you
read it really quickly like you're
immersed in it's really good when you
read it over the course of days weeks
like you forget what's happening and
you're just not invested you don't care
100
that's how i feel yeah so gary janet's
book is high on my list i'm in the
middle of stasis and i'm in the middle
of sally hepworth's new book
younger wife younger wife yeah very good
i'm about to read sassy's next but i
actually i'm excited because i feel like
there's a lot of books that i want to
read right now whereas i did go through
a drought a few months ago but i hate
being in the middle of multiple books i
know that's where i was in the middle of
three books at once i hate that i just
finished two and now i can get back to
stasis even though i was on like page
seven you should read josh pecks you
will love it add it to the list you will
love it it is so well written also
speaking of books i just want to remind
you that the new episode of the redheads
is out rave reviews as always and the
next book that we're reading this would
be i know it's never too late and it's
always a good time but this would be an
extra good time because the next book
that we're reading is run rose run by
james patterson who's like you know
james patterson
james patterson and dolly parton they
wrote a book together
accompanying soundtrack and she wrote an
album of songs to go with the book the
book is about like a singer-songwriter
on the run i believe her name is
rose run rose
run run run rose run right and i imagine
that the songs on the album are the
songs that they're referencing in the
book you know james patterson is a funny
fella let me tell you why first of all
he's obviously like you know did you
write the da vinci code no and that was
dan brown same thing so he's like this
prolific writer he's so rich he's always
popping up in weird places first of all
he does commercials for his books which
is just so
random like i've never seen a commercial
for a book have you
well his i mean i never really thought
about it but that's a good point so he
just like sits and he likes tells the
tale of his book but he also was in the
jeffrey epstein documentary on netflix
filthy rich because he was a neighbor to
jeffrey epstein in palm beach so like
he's just like kind of a weird guy but
like very into the energy he's putting
out i just want to say but he's always
popping up in random places james
patterson he is and he's literally
written like a million books and they're
all new york times bestseller it's like
forever he's so rich
yeah he what's his net worth his oh let
me let me look it up i just wanted to
like see how many books he's written
like sometimes i'll look at the new york
times list and it's like this book by
james patterson is on it's part on the
list for 67 weeks part of the alex cross
series it's the 22nd book right alex
cross series right he's a kind of
stereotype in that way you know what i
mean like yeah no he's
he
70 million dollars no it's got to be
more it's gotta be more that's so
impressive
yeah
so impressive he's like top he's like
stephen king jk rowling like top five
authors so i got a new phone this is
like
a totally random tangent and like
explain to me why they have to change
random things on the new phone just to
make you sick okay tell me why i go to
safari you know i want to tap the top of
the screen to go to the
to put a link in no they moved it to the
bottom yeah you want to go back to the
top you're kidding yeah but we've all
ready experiences oh no wait how there's
and you're also experiencing the most
annoying update which is when you're
facetiming with someone all of a sudden
well not all of a sudden you left the
screen for a little did your own thing
and you can't get back to the facetime
oh not only that snitch told me how to
get back this new phone it's like oh
we're gonna put you on do not disturb
whenever we [ __ ] feel like it yeah
that didn't happen to me also when now
when you facetime you're in portrait
mode
yeah i know how to turn it off but i
like it it's kind of cool you're like
tom brady how do i move it back to the
top
uh that's a really good question
settings settings all right i'll figure
that out later settings no this new
phone it's like they just wanna change
by the way the phone is works exactly
the same as my old one it's not that
much better the camera is exactly the
same but they want to be like yeah we
did something new that's why you spend
1300 on a new phone so we're gonna make
you sick and change all the little
features that you got used to yeah no
they're making you sick for sure they're
torturing the people new update for
those of us who don't watch who don't
have tick tock but sometimes watch
videos that our sister send us they play
in safari you watch the video you leave
a few minutes later your phone starts
making noise it's the next video playing
in safari they're really making it as
painful as possible for them
yeah they've been doing this for a while
now and also if someone does a really
long tick tock you can't watch the whole
thing i think we get like a minute i
don't know and now your phone just like
starts playing and it's it's so weird
just download tick tock not gonna happen
i would lose hours days years off my
life you're such a principled person
like you just you made this decision
you're actually acting like me a little
bit like so stubborn
i guess there is some
similarities between being stubborn and
being principled okay also we discovered
over the weekend
that i am a colonizer on jackie's
interests and choices because um like
not only do i
make fun of her for like all of her
interests but like then i'll like get
into her interest and then i make them
my entire personality like downton abbey
reading reading like i wouldn't read i
wouldn't watch downton abbey i made so
much fun of you you would talk about i'd
be like oh my god shut the [ __ ] up
already and then like slowly like years
later i got into it and like now
literally like i'm gonna start my own
rating podcast and my own downton abbey
podcast yeah yeah no i apologize for
that but i feel like if i'm
acknowledging that i'm doing it like it
makes it better you're acknowledging the
space and um i'm just glad you're
finally into the things that i'm into
though it takes time and it's just what
frustrates me the most is like even
though all the time
for sure but i can that passes in the
past i'm looking forward and even though
you know that eventually you're gonna
come onto my train like you still fight
me every step of the way like if i pick
something up right now you make fun of
me until it's your thing too yeah yeah
yeah but like what are you referring to
right now um
i don't know i don't know what it is
today okay
um also
i do want to say like that trait that i
have is probably my least favorite
quality in other human beings like if
i'm into something and then like my
friend gets into it and then like she
makes it her thing and everyone's like
oh yes sally loves you know
knitting i'm like [ __ ] like that's my
least favorite quality so like i'm
owning it but also i'm apologizing for
it and that doesn't mean i'm gonna stop
doing it but i'm owning it you know what
that could be
projecting it's like something that you
don't like about yourself so you don't
like about it in other people for sure
but i haven't liked that about other
people like my whole life and i really
feel like i only started doing it like
two years ago okay
um but i'm open to possible projections
i am i am
okay yeah that's what i think that is
when there's something you don't like
about yourself and like then it bothers
you and other people i think that's like
yes but like crazy but you've been
projecting by the way jackie but don't
you think like
it's not an ordinary for people to find
that trait annoying like you know what i
mean yeah
i think it's common do you ever get like
so deep in a conversation
sometimes like you get so like you try
and evaluate like a conversation so much
you eventually stop speaking english you
get lost in it it happens to me in bed
sometimes and like then i'll say
something and i'm gonna be like what
were we talking about
that just happened yeah that did like
can we just can we just move on to the
next story okay a little mother's day
news from priyanka chopra and nick jonas
they reveal that their baby girls spent
100 plus days in the niku on their first
mother's day nick and pre are opening up
about parenthood the couple shared the
first photograph of their baby girl and
uh shared their journey on instagram on
sunday
nick reflected on welcoming his little
one into the world earlier this year in
the caption of his post while also
celebrating priyanka on her first
mother's day he said on this mother's
day we can't help but reflect on these
last few months and the roller coaster
we've been on which we now know so many
people have also experienced after a
hundred plus days in the nicu our little
girl is finally home
every family's journey is unique and
requires a certain level of faith and
while ours was a challenging few months
what becomes abundantly clear in
retrospect is how precious and perfect
every
is how perfect precious and perfect
every moment is we are overjoyed that
our little girl is finally home that is
so sad and i was actually thinking
yesterday i think i said it to you i'm
like i always forget that nick and
priyank gotta be because they announced
it very surprised
very um
subtly and like never really followed up
on it and i guess this is now why yeah
that they're finally home with their
baby because we had known that she was
born prematurely because they shared
when they expected her versus like when
um she was born but i didn't realize i
don't think anyone really did that uh
they were going through this but i'm
happy that they are all together now 100
days is such a long time and i'm sure
every day feels like an eternity like
with olivia when kaler was in the nicu
like going there every single day it's
like a battle show and they and i think
she was in the nicu for like three weeks
mikayla and that's
21 days sorry that's five times the
amount like that's crazy really crazy
really sad but glad everyone is okay and
home and maybe this means now they'll
like start sharing more right
right because i i actually had forgotten
that they had a baby right
just a busy time for the jonas family
busy time also like you say nicu weird
niku i said nicu no you didn't you
didn't
nikku you said i mean there's no it's
not a word it's an acronym an acronym so
i could say it however the buckeye
that's incredibly true you can i'm sorry
everyone no jumpy
nikki
also
we love to have little um trinkets on
our couch and today we got the most
important trinket of all it's been
getting hottest [ __ ] here these days
and that's a silent fan it's a silent
fan we got ourselves handheld fans
claudia you got me one i'm not like i'm
not i'm not hot right now but this last
week i don't know maybe i was stressed
about msg but like i was literally
dripping with sweat no i was dripping
too like my crevices were moist every
time we got up yeah back my knees but
it's also because we're always wearing
sweatshirts you gave me no there's an on
and off button on the bottom and then
you have to press the okay
and there's just like nothing better
than a fan
okay so she didn't oh here it is so we
have instruments we have appliances yeah
we have drinks we leave everything we
need speaking of drinks tomorrow's a big
day for sprit society if you listen to
our patreon you watched our patreon
spirit society um taste test you would
know that we are finally launching a
variety pack so all the flavors in one
box and it launches tomorrow so if
you're on the patreon we got a code for
you so you should
check it out check that out our next
story sam hunt's pregnant wife hannah
lee fowler calls off their divorce
after everything sam hunt's pregnant
wife is reportedly giving him a second
chance after filing for divorce twice
earlier this year due to infidelity
allegations on the country singer's part
hannah lee fowler asked the court to
dismiss her request in april and it was
approved according to legal documents
obtained by tmz on sunday sources also
told the outlet that the married couple
have recently been spotted walking their
dog together in franklin tennessee hunt
has not confirmed the reconciliation and
his reps did not immediately return a
request for comment
but the court docs say what they say wow
i mean
she's pregnant so like even though i
think sam hunt is the most toxic human
being on the [ __ ] planet like i have
so much hate in my heart for him
um
you know you're gonna do what you what
you can
to raise the child in you know a stable
home so like i understand why this is
happening i'm sure like being pregnant
during this very emotional time is like
really you know
makes you really volatile
so um i get it especially last night
after watching it's complicated like you
know sometimes
you can go home again
interesting it's just really crazy
because i'm sure for her to especially
being like
celebrities for her to file initially
she no one even knew she was pregnant so
then that came up
citing infidelity came up
all your business is out there so to
take that really big step and put
everything out into the public you know
you must be really certain so then to
take it all back you must also be very
certain right so it's just a big swing
in the emotions right but it's common
for pregnancy it's right but
i guess yeah i don't think she's like
going back and forth because she's
pregnant but no she's having to make
colossal decisions because she's
pregnant and that's just not fair
honestly yeah like to be
in this position where you have to make
such life-changing
momentous decisions and like you are
extremely vulnerable yeah like it's
really not so much to ask for these men
to just like keep it in their pants for
10 months right no i it's it's so out of
control like
it's
it ain't right so like i said hate in my
heart for sam hunt i was about to say
sam smith sam smith is a nice guy like
sorry to sort of brought him into this
it's okay it's confusing yeah but sam
hunt is like literally one of my least
favorite people
we know i feel like we know right i knew
yeah and i don't want to go on my spiel
because i know you like to make fun of
me for only having five things to say
but like it's not five there's like 20
20. if i really sat down when he got a
dui and then like just moved on with his
life like hey you didn't i didn't i'm
still
physically i'm here mentally i'm a few
months ago where's sam hunt yeah i'm
still stuck there these things take time
yeah
are you ready for our next story which
is a little sports news only if it's a
sports news that's brought to you by
curology it is curology is a
game-changing custom skincare made for
you by a dermatology provider they'll
create a custom prescription cream for
your specific goals whether that's
tackling acne clogged pores skin texture
dark spots fine lines or something else
you'll start by taking a short online
quiz
and uploading photos and if it's a good
fit they'll ship you your formula right
to your door it even has your name on
the bottle so my specific formula is
targeting um my dry skin and i also have
dark spots around my mouth so i like the
fact that like you know jackie and i
both did curology and we got totally
different products because we literally
are different people with different skin
and the fact that like for a while we
all were just like using the same
skincare like it makes no sense same
right and so i love how custom
curology's curology is i love the quiz
because sometimes like you could think
like how great can my skincare be if i
ordered it online like you are getting
really really specific questions you're
taking really up-close pictures of your
of um of your skin and it's really
in-depth to get you the best possible
skin care you can get started just like
we did with a free 30-day trial at
curology.com
toast you just pay five dollars for
shipping and handling and that's
curology spelled
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com slash toast and start your free
30-day trial ending time and your
prescription is subject to consultation
you will definitely not regret starting
your curology journey whether you're
again trying to fight your acne fine
lines dark skin dark stark spots
anything that you want curology can fix
thank you claudia
it's a pleasure our next story some
sports news in a shocking upset well the
kentucky derby was this weekend is
kentucky terribly considered sports yes
okay
it's like the horses running not the
people just
yeah but would you consider uh nascar
sports
i don't know that's a good question why
don't you think about it the person who
asked a question like that is obviously
really smart
thank you claudia why don't you think
about it no i
because i asked a question like about
kentucky dirty to me like that's not a
good question like i know the answer you
don't think it's a good question i know
the answer honestly like i know sports
nascar you're sitting like okay really
okay so if not ready okay wait if nascar
nascar fans if nascar drives right there
if nascar drivers are athletes like so
am i we both sit for a living
no i'm totally kidding yeah sure it's a
sport whatever okay so some sports moves
i don't know actually okay do you think
those jockeys are athletes yes
okay but now horseback riding is an
eliminated sport now i'm fixated on that
sport okay who's like the biggest
dale jimmy johnson
is that his name
yeah dale earnhardt
no football coach bush
with this sch
yeah jimmy johnson hottie um he's
american prof they don't call him an
athlete on wikipedia american
professional auto racing driver okay but
like if you look up lebron james do they
say american professional basketball
player yes that's exactly what they say
that's a good question hold on do they
call him an athlete lebron james
wikipedia
basketball player yeah
interesting it's just something to think
about to chew on i know where i land on
this debate but it's obviously not as
obvious it doesn't mean that much too no
no that's not what i was gonna say it's
not such an obvious thing i feel like
we're getting to the point in the
conversation like we did last time we're
like we're not gonna know what we're
talking about i know we're talking about
the fact that con
horse racing is a sport yeah kentucky
derby was this weekend part one of the
triple crown and it was a huge upset and
a shocking upset rich strike won the
2022 kentucky derby at 80 to 1 odds the
longest among all 20 horses in the race
it's the second biggest upset in the
derby's 148 year history behind doane
rail which won in 1913 as a 91 to 1 long
shot so i guess if you put like a
hundred dollars on it you would have won
8 000 or 800
80 times 100 is 8 000
no it's yeah it's 8 000 yeah that's
crazy
no that's insane now i'm like wishing i
went to the derby right but would you
ever have put a hundred dollars on the
biggest loser well the thing is like for
me as a gambler like i wouldn't have
really looked at the odds i would have
looked at like whose name i liked the
most and honestly like i might have
chosen rich strike because it would have
been like oh man this is a sign he will
make me rich i could have seen a world
in which i put 50 on this horse i could
see that too because the other two
favorites were epicenter which i don't
think speaks to you no and zandon i
don't think speaking what other horse
names were there okay let me because i'm
really more of like a i'm a linguistical
kind of girl like words mean a lot to me
uh-huh that's so easy so if i went to
the teller and they were like which
horse do you want to put it on and i
looked at the names like i would have
been like which one of these
words means the most to me and i do love
the concept of being rich
so rich strike i probably would have put
my money behind okay so rich strike
epicenter this is an order of who won
epicenter zandon simplification no mo
donegal no barbara road no tawny park
tawny port no smile happy
that might have gotten you yeah cause i
would have been like
ah you know yeah you would have been
like yeah
tis the bomb
that's pretty good i might have done
that zozos no classic causeway no taiba
no crown pride no happy jack
i would be like oh my sister shaggy's
here with me you know
what if i wasn't there no that's what i
meant like in spirit she would want me
to do this
messier
no white abarrio no charge it no that's
kind of good cyber knife i just want to
say these names suck these names are
crazy what goes into naming a horse mine
would be disgraced queen 100 what would
yours be oh my gosh redhead
oh redhead is cute maybe bryson dyson
what about bryson dyson streisand dora
streisand chryson mason mine would
actually be doo doo doo doo
mine would be streisand
no lie no lie that would be my horse
yeah streisand bryce still streisand no
and then you'd have the gay community
behind you because they think you were
naming the
horse after barbara right but you're
obviously naming it after bryce bryson
streisand right and in
a weird way it's actually named after
bruno mars
because that's who bruno is named after
got it
summer is tomorrow
no it's not ethereal road
i was in my listing oh my god i'm sorry
i didn't realize that i was still
talking about the names i was back to
the list like summer's not tomorrow i
was in my listing boys summer is
tomorrow terrible name ethereal road
road fun rattle and roll i agree that
rich strike might have struck you yeah
in a profound way in a profound way and
did you watch the aerial video of rich
strike coming up from the back it was
honestly it was giving seabiscuit
secretariat it really was giving major
motion picture it's giving definitely
gonna have some sort of film and i will
be the first in line only if rich strike
goes on to do well in the next two races
yeah that was like really crazy and as
someone who loves the movie secretariat
it was it was giving secretary because
secretary always came from behind
because he wouldn't use all of his
energy
in the first few stretches right which
is a a good strategy it clearly clearly
i wonder who the like how much money
someone won on rich strike like the most
oh let's i don't know if they share that
information
rich i was just going to ask the dumbest
question shambler winner where does the
kentucky derby take place
i'm guessing kentucky that's a really
good question what's the second race not
the belmont that's the third one
i don't know
but we gotta go we gotta get some hats
and go
to the kentucky journey because i've
been to one of them i've been to the
belmont what yeah that's like a thing
you do when you live in new york city
like post grad living
i've never been it was
torture why absolute torture like you
take the train there because it's on the
train station
and so much standing oh and it was just
like not wearing the right shoes they
didn't give me any arch support um and
then you have to like take the train
home
and the race itself is really short and
that was the year that there was like
some really big buzz
around a horse had one two and it was
like american pharaoh no it was like
california king bed okay and you've got
this
king
you guys will remember um and it was
just not my day yeah and that's all i'll
say about it cause it's like a long
journey it took an hour on the train
five minutes at the track an hour back
on the train yeah
but also i think there are different
like ways you can go
and i wasn't in the like hats and heels
and dresses
space maybe if i went like and made a
day of it like that i would have enjoyed
it more probably not interesting um
i'm looking oh okay here's a story for
you from kentucky.com
stephanie rogers hadn't won a race all
day
rogers whose husband works at churchill
downs in louisville was able to take in
saturday's kentucky derby as a fan but
she had failed to find success betting
on the races
she began betting around the seventh
race of saturday's 14 race card and
unsuccessfully bet xactas up until the
148th running of the kentucky derby at 6
57 pm that's when stephanie strayed from
her usual betting strategy at the urging
of her son
i don't usually do win bets rodgers told
the herald leader but she did this time
and she won big she placed three dollars
on rich strike the 80 to 1 long shot at
a position number 20. that was the only
in the derby field after the friday
morning scratch of ethereal road well
they're really just tell us how much you
are making a meal
so what's 80 times three roger said her
son told her to do the bet because of
rich strikes long odds just kind of
picked the longest shot and said why not
and then she won
how much
it's a shame
kentucky she won about 280 dollars from
her bet
that's it
it's a shame she didn't follow with her
habit of placing exact because because
if she did two dollars with an exactica
she would have made four
thousand so
so the person who won the most is 280
dollars this is just the tale of one
woman
and she was the first one who came up
the first one who sold her story
for too happy for her i'm happy for it's
a big week and i'm happy for her son
he's obviously like the
the hero of the day right
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
no you're gonna hate this one more
meta is opening its first vr store
physical store selling vr headsets as
they inch closer to mainstream reality
meta platforms
facebook alt
formula
formerly known as facebook is opening
its first physical store to sell items
like its oculus quest 2 headset this
week the facebook parent company is
prepared to lose 10 billion dollars on
its hardware division
this year and reported a loss close to
three billion dollars in the most recent
quarter some experts say it may only
take one or two killer apps for the
metaverse to boost vr use from a mere
five percent of teens to a bigger market
now i'm not an expert in tech
predictions etc you're not but stop
trying to make vr happen it's not going
to happen i completely agree it's not
the vibe stop literally for so long now
at least five years we've had google
lens we've had oculus spectacles oculus
and the people who want to be like this
in their living room right are doing it
but most of us do not want it and i know
that everyone is placing
so much
hope hope and even money into
the media
and alternate realities and i just don't
think it's going to happen i like this
world it's not perfect sure no no
definitely not but it's a good one no
and it exists like it's real it's
tangible and the idea and i know i'm
shirking like every single ted talk and
and panel that's been taking place but
the idea that like we're going to be
buying real estate in the metaverse like
big money i'm going to spend i don't
even own a home here so i can spend on
my couch and be like this
i just maybe i just don't have the
vision
but i don't get it is that i think the
technology of vr and ar is helpful in
other things
like i know it's helpful in like
medicine and like other technology i
think the technology of ar and vr helps
to create other things but this
commercial idea that like we're gonna
sell people vr and like make things for
your home like glasses and and this
thing yeah i don't think like it's
necessarily like a b2c concept yeah and
that the whole world is going to be
living in the metaverse soon so we're
all just sitting on our couches living
elsewhere like then it's just like okay
what about then you start to think about
like what about the national parks we're
just gonna leave those like sitting
dormant such a valid question why would
i want to go to a national park in the
metaverse when there's beautiful geysers
to be seen in the real world god's
creations why do i want to watch mark
zuckerberg's waterfall when god has
created beautiful ones no it's so true
and honestly like i think a lot of how i
personally feel about this and maybe
it's be youtube it's like it's just my
general like vibe about meta like i just
don't like like anything they do or
trust them but like and so this bothers
me but like for some reason like
whenever amazon does something i'm like
that's a good idea okay i feel that way
in general and even take the meta out of
it because i think they just like jumped
on to this idea of like meta versus and
that call themselves meta but like other
places are building these communities
and worlds too and i still think
it's just not the vibe stop say
same but i don't know maybe if amazon
got involved i would be like maybe this
has a future
well if amazon got involved it would
make me think it had a future because
they don't get involved in small change
right no but like if i just got involved
if elon got involved right like i just
like literally hate mark zuckerberg and
like his whole energy and everything he
creates he said i love instagram and
it's giving me a platform and a life but
like you know what i mean thank you mark
thanks mark i actually should shut the
[ __ ] up like he literally has a power
one button
i'm broke you know yeah
no
it's not even a mark zuckerberg issue
for me it's just like a what's wrong
with this world issue for me and what we
should create another one that we can
ruin like maybe we should just fix this
fix this one yeah fix the issues at hand
no i think that's really really a valid
point and i love the energy i just
i don't know i think people need to like
focus on the physical world more
yeah i agree and like i don't think
you know
submerging ourselves into other worlds
is going to be good for our mental
health like i just think it's a lot no
um mental health our physical health
yeah
no it really is like black mirror and
there's just like no accountability i
could be anyone who i want to be in the
metaverse right no like remember that
episode of black mirror where landon
from friday night lights is like this
loser in the real world and then at
night he like puts on his metaverse
goggles and he like has kidnapped people
in other worlds and he's like a [ __ ]
sadistic freak yeah that's what's gonna
happen like duel personalities and he
can't get out and he kidnapped all these
people from his office and took them
people who were maintained in his office
he like took them into a special
universe and tortured them and took them
away from their friends and family that
was messed up that was the craziest
episode there were no not the craziest
no
sorry did we all forget about the pig
no we're not going there but anyways
those are just my initial thoughts on
the metaverse you know always i'm open
to being wrong and i don't like know a
ton about all this stuff it just like
rubs me the wrong way do you feel the
same way about like bitcoin i was just
about to say i don't feel the same way
about like nfc
no
nfts that's that's a different
conversation i don't feel that way about
cryptocurrency even though i don't fully
understand it
i see it right and i think it's a valid
currency yeah i can sense it i think
that it's real and elon's all in there
for i am in but i'm not only just in
because of elon but you know his seal of
approval doesn't mean it doesn't hurt to
a girl like me right who doesn't
understand such things right no i agree
i feel the same way because it's so it's
not like we're totally against like new
image tech i'm not not at all no
and
nfts
i'm sorry it's gonna be a no for me i
agree big no and that's something i see
i could be wrong about someone once
explained it to me and i got as close as
i could to seeing the value
and like actually if i was someone who
saw value like we could really nft the
[ __ ] out of our show okay so i actually
like i don't even think i ever told you
it's like i had like a full call with
like a company that had all these ideas
for how we could become like nft queens
and i was really really like into
understanding it i was but then i was
like
but what if i screenshot it like that's
that's literally like the loophole in
the whole thing
yeah just take a screenshot
yeah
i came really close to understanding and
then i went back to the real world and i
was like no no then you like got it and
that's what i think happens i think like
this metaverse and nfts is really a part
of that because you buy art that you
would hang on your house in the
metaverse right yeah i don't know
because like you don't physically get
anything yeah and i just think it's p
it's kind of like a cult like they're so
they're in another world it's so true
and i'm in this one and for that reason
it's giving nexium yeah we just can't
connect no we cannot
those are my thoughts well that was a
very interesting little tech segment
thank you so much jackie for bringing
that up oh and so my thoughts about uh
meta like creating physical stores for
people to try on these headsets they
can't even buy them in the stores they
have to actually buy them on they have
to order them
it's giving moronic it's giving moronic
those are my thoughts but i mean they're
investing so much money in it that maybe
it's not but maybe it is yeah but also
like that's a similar model to tesla
like when you go into a tesla store you
can't buy a tesla well that's like a
bigger purchase right you know so it's
like what's the point of the stores
to try them out i would no there's not
even there's no cars on the stores okay
but do they show you how well i honestly
have no idea what goes on in the stores
they're like literally empty we have to
go yeah
we need a tesla yeah because you don't
even know how to drive but they drive
themselves i know i do still think you
need a license to operate one i do
believe that as well but if it dries so
well like why should i get pulled over
and have to show my license no when
tesla makes a convertible like it's over
yeah i think they're close yeah that's
really the next frontier because they
have the pickup truck that's the only
thing like you know i've been getting a
lot of teslas around the city for uber
like i get them i got literally happened
yesterday and the day before and i love
the inside i think the apparatus is so
cool but like we all need to talk about
how the outside is like literally so
ugly like it's getting it's giving mom
car like it's giving millions there are
so many different kinds there are some
that are really sleek there are some
that is you know are giving um
prius prius or what's the car that's
every toyota camry yeah but it's toyota
camry batmobile edition yeah but like
once they really start investing in like
sickening like make it look like a
convertible then i'll get one because
they're [ __ ] like expensive
and
i just like
i want to look cool in my car they have
different tiers like they have an
affordable
option no i no i get it and like the one
david dobert has which is like the most
sick expensive one like it's giving
station wagon is it yeah you need to
lock it up yeah david debrick is like
the one with the bat moby like the wings
come up
got it it doesn't look like just like a
bmw x5 no it's literally giving
cars it's giving back uh it's giving
minivan well that is a sleek look for me
minivan
uh yeah i love a minivan i know you're
gonna be a minivan mom
you love minivans i do i love being in
the back though i don't know how i feel
in the front right is this what you're
talking about yes
okay to me that looks like
like a bmw x5 but i could see how you
know to be an untrained guy right yeah
thanksgiving minivan um all right let's
dive into unburden ourselves which is
our monday segment where people write in
and unburden themselves with the
embarrassing things they did over the
weekend and it's brought to you
by money with katie
you should check out money with katie
from the morning brew finance bros are
out and rich girls are in katie gotti
knows about money and she's here to help
you manifest your financial freedom join
katie and her guests as they talk
spending habits smart investing and tax
strategies without putting you to sleep
listen weekly on wednesdays to learn how
to turn your rich girl mindset into
money and you can listen wherever you
get podcasts so a lot of the recent
episodes they just discuss topics like
the most dangerous misconceptions about
the four percent withdrawal rate why
renters and owners alike would benefit
from a housing market cooldown how to
buy back your time outsourcing tasks
investing the age of overvalued stocks
and homes and why you may need to save
less for your retirement than you think
she also has a blog and a newsletter
that are released weekly as well as free
downloadable tools and documents for
money management and budgeting so that's
money withkaty.com and you can check out
money with katie from the morning brew
on wednesdays wherever you get your
podcasts
unburden ourselves yourselves so if you
ever want to write in it's unburdened
yourselves gmail.com and trust me like
you may think like i can't say this it's
too embarrassing but once you let it go
like you will feel so much better you
free yourself hi claudia and jackie last
night i went to dinner with my friends
at my boyfriend's restaurant it was a
lovely time look at you boyfriends right
like subtle subtle humble brag it was a
lovely time but i was feeling backed up
all day so i drank a lot of water at
dinner the food was really rich and
delicious after dinner i got caught in
some traffic and it took me about an
hour to get home as it was running from
my car to the bathroom i [ __ ] my pants
i [ __ ] my pants i'm a 32 year old woman
and this hasn't happened to me in years
i didn't want to tell my boyfriend
because i don't i don't want him to
think there's anything wrong with the
food he cooked no because there is but
there is no but she said she was backed
up all day and then chugged so much
water so like it was just about time
still i really don't believe like
unless you're sick you can you can
clench it's painful it's uncomfortable
but i think that like just being backed
up and everything moving so quickly in
an hour because you drank water like i'm
sorry you were poisoned no that's that's
an interesting conspiracy
yeah and i mean really rich foods can
hurt your stomach
but that's on the food no i don't think
you should tell your boyfriend not
because you don't want him to think that
you um were poisoned you shouldn't tell
your boyfriend because then like you
know the magic is gone right you just if
he didn't bear witness to it like you
don't need to tell him not everyone
needs to know everything like and i
think that's really important i think
that's important too but don't blame
yourself for this no yeah agree because
like a a dinner out shouldn't make you
shake your pants no matter what you did
earlier that day and you know what just
unless you like took a laxative really
think about water really think about how
much worse it could be like at least you
were right outside your house not like
in a public setting where you like you
could literally go in throw your clothes
away take a shower and the whole saga is
behind you so i would be grateful for
that you know like you weren't an hour
outside like joey camasta in the back of
your uber you know i have one thing to
say what juliana i drink a lot of water
i know you know thank you for
unburdening yourselves i honestly don't
think that that was that big of a deal
like just always think about how much
worse things could be and then you'll
feel so much better and it's also not
your fault right exactly there's no
really personal accountability that
needs to be taken here none
next up hey claudia and jackie i did
something so incredibly embarrassing at
work this week and i absolutely need to
unburden myself it was my first week
back at work after six months of
maternity leave wow six months where do
you work
on my first day i was doing the rounds
around the office saying hi to my
colleagues that i hadn't seen in six
months but then i bumped into the ceo i
don't know him super well as it's a big
company and we don't work together
closely but he knows who i am and he
knew it was my first day back he looked
at me and said hey welcome back and he
extended his arms for a hug what the
[ __ ] i was caught off guard since i
don't usually hug my co-workers let
alone the ceo so due to me panicking we
ended up in this weird half-hug where my
face was squished directly into his
chest and he had his arms wrapped around
me when i emerged from his embrace i
noticed that all of my
makeup
foundation had rubbed off on the on the
front of his black hugo boss cardigan it
looked like the perfect print of my
ivory colored face on his shirt oh my
god he didn't notice the stain but my
face turned red like a tomato and i for
some reason was too embarrassed to point
it out so i just walked away i sat at my
desk the rest of the day watching him
walk around the office
with my makeup all over his chest later
in the day i saw someone pointed out
to him and helped him wipe the stain off
the sweater i could see the ceo racking
his brain and looking around trying to
figure out what caused the massive face
shape stain on his shirt i just dunked
down in my chair and i never looked up
for the rest of the day i don't know why
this is so embarrassing but i'm still
getting knots in my stomach thinking
about it sincerely
a girl who needs to get a new setting
spray okay uh i would be so embarrassed
too but i think you're okay cause i
really don't think he knew it was you
plus he's clearly a hugger could have
been the other person he hugged or you
know if he hugged multiple people and if
he didn't immediately you know oh that's
a face and that's makeup like men don't
realize that that's makeup he when he
sees a stain he's not thinking makeup
like he's probably thinking oh i spilled
something no what i was going to say was
like
even if he did know it was makeup
the fact that he walked around for hours
with it really puts you in the clear
like you know how many people he's a ceo
you know how many people he interacts
with like meetings meetings meetings so
you're just now one of 10 people it
could have been and that is better he's
not going to put it together first he
needs to realize that it's makeup yeah
then he needs to retrace his steps this
is a man who hugs like he you're
probably not the only hug he had that
day and even if it was he might men
don't like remember these things like
you did without seared into their memory
right like thinking that was a weird hug
for him it's just like one of many
altercations he has throughout his day
as ceo yeah and you know what he's just
he's not worried about where it came
from he's feeling like a clown that he
walked around with it so he's like he
has subverted himself to us now
everyone's just thinking about
themselves you're fine yeah that's the
best advice and that's really at the end
of the day like what unburden yourselves
always comes down to like you can be
thinking about it so much but at the end
of the day you have to realize like
literally nobody cares about you and i
mean that in the nicest way possible
like no one is thinking about you no one
is looking at you no one is thinking
like when they go home about the thing
that you did like just you they're
thinking about the thing that they did
you just have to switch your perspective
yeah 100
third and final
hey girlies i recently traveled to nyc
with two of my best friends to celebrate
my 21st birthday we had a whole weekend
planned on my birthday and we were going
to the comedy cellar and then going out
being three non-new york girlies we
definitely missed the right train we
missed the show and i was bummed my
friends quickly pulled me into a bar to
calm me down and we made a plan and of
course i just started drinking in true
21st birthday fashion people were buying
me drinks and shots and the bartenders
were really just giving me things of
course i was living for it but i soon
did pay at the end of the night drunk
and happy i called an uber and rounded
out my friends and we started our 15
minute drive back to the hotel in the
car i started feeling a little sick but
i thought i could breathe through it and
make it boy was i wrong a sudden urge
and it all came back up the most
disgusting part being my mask was still
on oh no
it was all over me and my clothes but
the only thing i could think about
was the cleaning fee i sat entirely in
my filth mask filled with vomit until i
could get out hoping i was sneaky enough
for the uber driver not to notice i then
fell out of the uber onto the road and
had to walk through the lobby and
upstairs would throw up all over me and
my friends warning others not to get in
the elevator with us while filming me so
embarrassing but proud to say i did not
get charged to cleaning fee so she kept
it in some things you know what like
i'm all about being financially
responsible but like some things
are worth paying for and to um just
unhook your mask and let the vomit out
from underneath your nose and mouth just
to pay like a 50 to 200 cleaning fee
like that's worth it yeah it wouldn't be
the cleaning fee that i feel bad about
it would be like the driver yes the car
where i
soiled yeah um and i'm not going to
judge you because i was about to i was
about to be like who does this you know
what me on my 21st birthday i had the
exact same night as you did so i'm in
literally no position to judge happy
birthday it's a rite of passage um
agreed it wasn't my 21st birthday it was
my first night out in college and i was
in the back of an uber this has actually
happened to me twice
um i was in the back of an uber like
drinking a lot i think i actually smoked
a cigarette which was like not something
i would ever do a drunk cigarette will
kill kill you so i'm in the back of a
car i'm with my friends you're not a
smoker yeah i'm with my friends alyssia
and layla i'm like you guys i'm gonna
throw up and i literally made a bowl
with my hands threw up the perfect
amount chucked it out of the window and
all was good
then the second time it happened um
was a few years later i smoked pot and
i'm really not a good pod smoker i got
so anxious i was in this apartment i was
like oh my god i have to go to the
bathroom like i'm so anxious i could die
i don't know what's going on and then
all of a sudden i just even though i was
in the bathroom i threw up in my hands
and all my anxiety went away i guess
like the throw up coming up my system
was
coming through as anxiety but it was
just throw up i threw up my hands and
then i had a great time that's great
yeah no
you're 21 like that's what you're
supposed to be doing on your birthday
and it's really gross um
but that's that's what happens and i
think you might have had worse anxiety
and had to unburden yourselves even more
if you had thrown up in this nice man's
car yeah
yeah the mass part like but
there's always going to be you know some
some grossness to it yeah but it's a
21st birthday yeah and it's a sign of
the times that you threw up in your mask
um well that was unburdened yourselves
thank you to everyone who was vulnerable
with us this is always a safe space most
of the time and if you ever want to
unburden yourself it's unburden yourself
gmail.com it's plural unburden
yourselves at gmail.com we keep it
anonymous and we just try to make you
feel better because mondays are hard
enough all you ladies or gents who wrote
in this week you're good you're good
yeah you're good
nothing that will haunt me you know and
i've had some things on this show that
really stuck with me yeah but forgive
yourselves you guys it's okay it's fine
um and that's our show that is our show
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the milan morning show
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the past five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio cast box all the places so every
listen podcast find out some morning
chelsea 5 star review about how
beautiful about how stunning about how
smart we are have an amazing day you
guys will see you tomorrow in studio
with the snatchler
i'm so excited for you and i'm so
excited as a viewer
snitch on the toast
snitch on the toast a snitch on the
toast but i'm thumb snitch on the toast
we'll see you tomorrow don't miss it bye